I leave in all you on your way back home
either way we wanna be there doesn't
matter how much baggage you clean give
us time and a terminal and gate we want
to send you off in style we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared her was fine now horn
do you
do you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need
with Karen and Chris welcome to do you
need a ride this is Chris Fairbanks
Jericho Guerra we are near LAX god it's
gorgeous just kind of hovering around it
like a nervous schoolgirl like an orb
someone you know could be intimidated by
our behavior like a nervous schoolgirl
or a possible terrorist yeah we are
hovering around LAX we might we might
have bad intentions mal-intent but not
this time no way we're picking up the
delightful I'm Johnson yeah me I go
around yeah let's do it um jake has just
landed he is a major celebrity in the
comedy world he sure it's to me i I've
looked up to him as a comedian sense
before I even started doing this stuff
yeah he's I remember seeing him on
Letterman long ago where he did his joke
about it it's not guns that kill hit
people it's bullets cuz she right
remember that joke you're something like
that were then he does a whole thing
about pushing a bullet into someone's
head oh right that's funny or maybe it
was the opposite people are saying it's
not guns don't kill people people kill
people but you really do need the gun to
get the bullet in right yeah something
along this what is the it's like a nail
building a house right without a hammer
yeah it's very much like that i think
that almost deserve like a rejoicing
sound of recognition for me just coming
up with for how accurate that was of you
already accurate yet to do yeah I don't
what kind of reducing sound would you
like to hear exactly like saying oh okay
exactly let's do it again let's dumb
let's start over Oh Bella yeah well
let's go people without a gun yeah and a
nail can build a house oh my god zactly
thank you well is that loud and horrible
and I was a little chriqui it
uh that's me from the beginning when I
started doing comedy people always like
to compare you to that's always fun a
fun game oh you're like a young new
heart I'm like I didn't even know he did
standup yeah then I learned he did and I
learned he's quite good at it but people
compare just because of people said I'd
talk like Ellen a little bit mm-hmm just
because of the stammering or whatever
but I also someone said take johansson
months and so I found and this was
pre-internet I don't know if I must have
ordered a VHS tape or something yeah but
I was like oh I get it that I like the
way that guy thinks and I think I met
him for the first time last year and I
may have said something stupid like we
have similar brains I don't know no he
had seen me judge we just did a show and
he liked what I did and I think while I
was on stage oh good he knew your
communion and man that I just done well
and I also because I just watched him I
do i do this sometimes where I kind of
will do an impression of someone yeah
and like when Kramer was in our on our
podcast i was talking like this little
time yeah I can't not do it that's the
third episode we've met you know I did
subtitle of this show is the Howard
Kramer yeah love cab we love Him it's
too bad too bad too bad i'll never know
unless he listen he'll never know oh
yeah i like the way Jake spring thinks
and we're gonna have his brain and his
body in the car shortly uh what I am
excited about and when I say excited I
kind of mean like nervous and fear-based
uh-huh because as everyone knows we talk
about it all the time this car is it's
moderately filthy just in the way that
you can't get dog hair off of your what
seemed to be fleece seats in this stupid
honda fit i think the inventor of velcro
had the same breed of dogs as you
hehe yeah it's Eureka moment one day
cleaning off the seats in his buggy I
don't know if this was buggy days when
the guy invented Grell felt but it's a
serious you know fell through I'm not
quite microscopic level their little
hooks a series of hooks and loops and
yeah this is what's happening yeah
there's a hook and loop dog hair
scenario happening this car I guess they
have split ends that's the only way to
explain the barbed hook it yeah the air
now I did read once that Martha Stewart
brushes her dogs twice a day and I don't
think I've ever brushed either of my dog
so maybe that's the the where the filth
is coming in Russia's her dogs yes in
between cookie make how come no one ever
12 Martha Stewart to get a goddamn job
you know just kidding cuz she was rich
but she didn't have to oh did she choose
one of those people Gilligan she's got
that dead look in the eye oh yeah that
uh you know like you were saying that
guy that like weird we're talking smack
about a few people bragging imagine it
now you'll have to get the photo shows
was like oh yeah blah blah I don't know
no we can't do that but it's she good we
should do that how's that look in her
eye where I'm like I don't trust her you
know what she knows she looks like the
painting that her eyes are her eyes and
then you slide her eyes out and your
eyes go in so you can spy on people Oh
like the scooby-doo painting yes that's
totally Martha Stewart's face someone
should do an oil painting of Martha
Stewart my case look at us like look at
the Y hey remember no we did I never do
this in a consecutive way that would be
like good like hooking back to another
episode I never do it recent enough but
on the dren adavis episode we were
jailed me much to my absolute joy with
your all of your scooby-doo voices oh
the entire cast yes yes I'm still
working on Fred my Daphne is on point uh
it's crappy also but um I found the
picture did you remember seeing and I
posted on Twitter where when I we were
talking about you being night crawler or
any ville
from scooby-doo and I found the pictures
where they look exactly alike yeah I was
really impressed by myself yeah findings
make sure the thing yeah oh I appreciate
that this is basically me taking a
moment to say hey remember that time
when I did that thing I and it's me up
Henry's calling and I don't have time to
talk to him let's just see what he wants
Henry Phillips everybody wants a guest
of this show yeah once a co-host turned
a guest in one episode uh am I I want to
turn left but am I allowed to I think I
am yes I am yes you are allowed great
this is a this part of LA which would be
considered what Oh tiara the lucky area
Michael would I don't know I don't it's
the single one I don't know it could it
be fox hills oh yes we are near the fox
hills mall lots of foxes running around
in the traffic oh it's almost like it's
a hazard while you're driving they have
foxes sometimes they're just blowing
around like dandelion spores just boxes
everywhere oh you're not allergic I have
yeah I have a fox haller it's gonna say
oh yeah when they're blowing around not
and i'm not talking about their dander
these are little fox that are airborne
tiny airborne fox by the urban fan you
bring them in oh I'll be damned if it
doesn't get me stuffed up okay yes um
still haven't heard from Jake but I know
he's in the airport he'd be all he will
be walking towards the outdoors and I
think this is gonna be one of those
episodes where we time it perfectly and
he will jump in seamlessly to our
arrival and we're gonna rejoice and
you're gonna squeal so glad us know your
rejoicing oh yes and now I now that I
know what rejoicings supposed to sound
like because exactly before this when I
was rejoicing I would go and I you know
I will make sound you've been giving the
wrong impression at all parties for 45
years yeah yeah yes absolutely true
happy birthday friend no I'm happy no I
I really am some might say overjoyed for
you Wow it doesn't you don't feel like
that in any way it feels like you're mad
at me well I'm not no one ever showed
you how to celebrate it's uh it is sad
actually it is sad now there's a there's
a sign in front that gas station over
there that says enjoy a cup of fresh hot
coffee and what's fascinating about that
is we both are right now I'm currently
holding one as its Karen and it is hot
the only thing that that sign isn't
letting everyone know I'm not really
enjoying it you're not yeah it's not
good college came out of a robot box at
the airport Sheridan where we stopped
thinking they had a starbucks on them
once we valeted the car and got inside
yeah not a not a story used to be a
starbucks oh really oh well now don't
you get a current employee of this not
starbucks to go take down that [ __ ]
sign here's the that's why I said I said
[ __ ] son yeah that's right upset with
you pay as hey out his fist on his hip I
said I'm right behind it sassy way
though like that yeah like a bossy kind
of mama shui he also had little Polly
yeah he was he was definitely working in
and he was singing that walk then I come
up behind him I come up in behind him
and I says hey I don't want some goddamn
coffee from Malaysia [ __ ] yeah
that's right um I shouldn't have yelled
that so loud there are several families
you and I both within the same minute
are regretting our F bomb drops we went
nuts at the airport Sheridan
yeah I don't know why no I mean just now
we both said the F word oh I know Roz
I'm very good about it you have been an
Emmy and then I just once I say it that
opens up the F word Karen co Garrett
floodgate oh my god it just startled all
the Senate's it sounds so natural to me
it's not so good oops I'm gonna go down
here oh yeah Airport Boulevard seems the
most appropriate it just work it just
fits it makes sense yeah I've been very
good about the swearing lately I've
noticed I've also started wearing
dresses and pinning my hair back did you
finally throw away your garbage pail kid
that said swear and Karen cuz that are
you go ahead and look it up everyone is
that real swearin Karen did she have a
little piece of dried lettuce on her
face uh that's why she's swearing she's
a goddamn salad so hard to even salad I
hate it are you gonna bump this van to
prove a point push it forward seems like
you're gonna bump this and we're gonna
roll it up I want to roll it forward and
is lurching towards this bumper and we
you are you cannot go any closer or I
will get nervous or you'll scream
whatever backs up what if there's an old
late and they need running and that's on
him being you can't just back up into me
you can't bring that this way because i
am not the one one time I was in a check
cashing place and sound like you were
auditioning for do the right thing yeah
right okay because I was in the check
cashing place and this homeless lady
came in and started saying the n-word oh
and everybody got super nervous all
everybody of every color of the rainbow
in that check was she a real uncle greg
lee haired white lady that's exactly
right I'm Hollywood Boulevard hate it
when it rolls off this also homeless
tongues and but so easy everybody just
pretended she wasn't there until she
tried to get in this probably six foot
seven black man who was standing behind
me wearing a beautiful suit he looked
like a banker and she tried she came up
and she started saying something to him
and he turned and goes uh you best not
be talking to me because I am not the
one and then she don't laugh she left
the building and it was one of the
coolest things I've ever seen I am
the one cuz I'm not the one that's great
it was a great way to get someone to I'm
not the person you're looking this this
is not he was saying you'll get your
seed will get no purchase here ma'am yes
your racial seed I wish that he had said
that can i change the story you could
your seed will grow no crops you will
not reap know so why are you honking
[ __ ] a [ __ ] racism active and alive
today it's a white Mercedes with a
person who is not a man and not do you
think they were being racist towards us
cuz we're why you did it doesn't make
sense see I can i canna thing you
absolutely can yeah well thank you good
sometimes classically trained
self-taught but in a classic way I made
myself sing while wearing a powdered wig
when Oh as a child oh I see the Mozart
style classic yes yes yes I was singing
piano and Adam Lallana see it's all
tongue I use a lot of tongue weight and
your mom dips her head in again Chris
your left or these silk pants on the
ground again oh you're so classically
self-taught Chris Chris get your
handkerchief out of here I wish you'd
classically clean your room self teach
her way to make some dinner every once
in a while oh yeah this is actually
starting to hit too close to home and
and I'm starting to feel sad I had a
boyfriend who's he's always cook dinner
oh my mom almost never cooked dinner she
was like girls Chinese food I would my
sister and I would go in the kitchen and
there would be food or something she
baked and we're like all right the
tables have turned and we start digging
in she's like that's for the office for
an office party it's like what what were
your family never make us we have never
seen such a casserole yeah I followed a
recipe
for the office my mom literally could
make two things and so she'd switch off
it would be baked chicken with minute
rice and some frozen corn or it would be
she called it three soup chicken where
it was like chicken with three cream
campbell soups on top and some almonds
throw it in the oven we called it a door
slammer a very minimal effort put in to
raising us I'll just say it now yeah I
guess I come from a long line of mothers
who didn't really weren't passionate
about cooking it's it's fine aspect I
mean no there's nothing more offensive
than saying hey a lady should be cooking
but I think that when you have kids you
should provide the base a meal a day the
base and that's not me being sexist I
think dad could do it too suddenly she
does he sell in dictionaries
door-to-door is that what he was a Bible
addiction no no um everybody's like I
already have a dictionary I have one
other yeah both my parents work and then
they come home late and who the hell
would wanna I don't even cook myself
meals well I can't imagine having kids I
can't imagine I definitely can't imagine
having kids but I certainly can't
imagine cooking meals ever it's my we
are stopping this might be the first
time they tell us we can't record let's
see you gonna act like I'm not a good
idea yeah just put that down yeah they
never up what he doesn't see is I just
put my microphone back to my face I had
it down whoo my helicopter lands in
front of us oh my god oh my god Tom
honey joans out get out okay on that
[ __ ] sorry officer please fly away now
okay I should do that
yeah Michael Winslow is here's why he's
underrated okay reason number what can
he do a better helicopter than that it
was pretty good though oh that's the
only reason he just does a better
helicopter than that that's that the
raging he deserves yeah good helicopter
noise maker he's right in there he's got
like a five point eight which is exactly
what he deserves one time eyes on radio
in Austin with that Robert Hawkins guy
who we've talked about usually thinking
is uh quite quite quite genius Michael
Winslow was on radio 2 and we were just
asking him to make the sounds of things
and we were like dude sausage sizzling
an enemy he made it sound it was just
coming out of his mouth and circling
popping noise that sounded like and then
and then in kind of a dick move Robert
said now do bacon and in did a
differences well yes that's awesome
different sound that was kind of thinner
so it's like well maybe where else is
that guy gonna perform guess he's not a
comedian to me not a guy that thinks of
jokes and but what he is is an
entertainment is an entertainer and
where the hell and he also does put
those sounds together he's a comedian in
that I mean there's some people who call
themselves comedians who are way worse
than Michael Winslow let's not be let's
not be near tradition right right who
are traditionally all the cool the
framework is there though the frame was
there the pr's there people call them
comedians and they work and they get
working clubs and you've heard them
you've heard their name constantly and
then perhaps are even lauded and are
actually rotten rotten this is the
option where we are talking about
specific people but we aren't saying who
they are it's got to be frustrating it's
gotta be you know what it's creating a
kind of hot dynamic tension for the
listener the listener is at home like I
know who that is to me do I know who
what means yeah does it even matter who
it means assign that comedian in your
own brain right we all hate a person de
zoom to be a KD and it could be that
lady in your office that's so irritating
don't your name don't say her name don't
even think it don't even just know that
you're writing know that she exists
that you hate her that you're right
there are you know the Internet age is
introduced this idea that everybody's
great and that's simply not true no just
read my youtube comments Oh God how
about that for a sound ecstatic joy
hahaha what I just did see that guy yeah
he looks pretty good with that guy's hot
it you know who knows what we're doing
he knows you knows he's hot as hell
looks like a he's the best dressed up
for a business meeting but it's about
wrestling he's got bad shoes so you know
it's about wrestling yeah yes it's
really bad good students always you know
jumping up on the roads and throwing
them using him as a weapon that's right
when there isn't a folding chair he's
used to a tall lace up boot that's
wedding yeah black black flat shoe
doesn't really yeah he's not good at
shopping for those they're all scuffed
up cuz he's tossed a metas co-workers
that guy looked like a beefier Statham
do you think the wrestlers call the
other wrestlers coworkers I guess this
is more of a Matt McCarthy question you
know yes yes I bet you if i text matt
right now we could work crash into a car
and then we would do it a PSA for not
texting while you drive i think we just
did it I didn't mean to jump down your
throat but your lane no texting during
this there will be no text vehicular
podcast look at that guy's a top hat on
anything or girl other than homicide be
vehicular oh oh oh yeah that was pretty
funny I don't think we have a vehicular
podcast well that's terrible and illegal
no I didn't say man we don't kill
anybody yeah no kids hurt we kill with
our yam are jokes [ __ ] kill that
crush I crushed in my car the other day
okay I don't see him I guess he's not
quite out here yet banana he still
hasn't should we be so so coffee is to
show brass brash brat brassy should we'd
be shinobi's route with our hair guy so
brassiere thank you oh my god somebody
oh that's a nice perk where are you from
out of town what are you
some kind of and now they're honking no
get in front of me I want I need someone
to honk at what I'm gonna sometimes I
let people in just so I can honk at them
Chris we're going around again we have
to go rhino I mean what are you solving
a crime don't leap out of your tax eat
your crazy ass yeah that really excited
to pick up a fare we almost clipped as
uh that cab driver jumped out on the
driver's side into airport traffic he's
such a calm look on his face but it was
a it was the body of an urgent man it
was probably he had already his spirited
left his body because she was committing
the look on that romantic he's like
looking for his loved ones if he look he
has a little kid's face yes he was lost
he was adorable no this guy's adorable
look at this old guy look at him he's
like I'll get it your dad I really act
my own oh he's throwing the is he
frustrated this damn had of my wife's
this stupid traffic oh he's sweet I
never really had a grandpa Karen you
dinner no oh I had a cut I had one great
grandpa I'm an awesome grandpa he was Oh
was he your Grandpa's dad or was he nice
awesome he was my dad's dad I didn't
mean to say Greg I'm so bad that was
madison davis joke she said she has this
great grandpa great grandma joke Oh was
she you're really old or just a really
good grandma and I did it wrong I told
it wrong it's basically what you just i
liked it i didn't understand what was
happening till the end cuz i was thinkin
about my grandpa who was the greatest
yeah mine Wyatt to I'd one there was a
grumpy and drank and one that was just
grumpy and crazy and didn't need drinks
to be that way they both were just tall
and mean and yeah they burn me once I
was like walking and talking they didn't
want anything to do with me you know
what there's nothing worse than a grumpy
old mansion they're the worst they're
scary looking they look like ghouls
you're making it very hard to respect my
elders yes sampha you if you're old
you're an old man and you make it to
that point just be nice like it have a
drink that's fine but be nice I wish
that yeah I wish my grandparent cuz it's
kind of the reason we left California
where I was born and went back to
Montana
my dad was like well the kids should be
around grandparents oh no I went down
there and then they just weren't into us
there like once I started I think I said
something I had an opinion about
something once and he never really
looked at me again because he was from
an era where you got to open hand slap
children right now or he would there'd
be the salt shaker would be empty and he
would just slide it across the floor and
it would hit my grandma's feet and
without flinching she would pick it up
and put salt in it and put it go like
that's called a few that's called love
yeah that's a yeah that's from a
different time yeah but they're all gone
now but so I never everyone's
grandparents are gone I'm not saying
that I don't you and I we Bev we have
we've had lost yeah we've had lost
because i'll leave the thing but I do
see old men and I'm like I yearned for
their attention and that's yearning a
things worse word I could have been i
miss it sound sexual I don't want to be
with them I want to just be with them
you want to have a nice a cardigan
sweater arm around your shoulder I was
in England I think there was all these
grandpa's I never had cuz i get i think
i'm vaguely english i don't know i don't
i haven't gone to ancestry.com but I
quit don't do it rip off it is okay
weird like military records and [ __ ]
alone please insert your teeth into the
computer I just uh but may see all these
old men uh like worse why is everyone
talking it's such hard its traffic you
doing everybody's fine Super Bowl Sunday
whose to talking oh who they're just
gonna keep honking sometimes people honk
when there's just they don't know oh
he's saying hi to his friend and we're
caught in the crossfire could it be that
go bro down on your end sorry you guys
are on your own yeah damn time the Super
Bowl happening right now it is happening
right now maybe well my my grand flowers
didn't like me they knew I didn't care
about football maybe that's what it was
and then my dad you know really are you
really taking that personally cuz if it
was an old alcoholic man it had nothing
to do with you right yeah I mean there's
there's a little work to be done there
yeah they were cool when I was really
little that's what matters when
informative count yeah you know when
you're 14 who wants to hang out with
your grandpa oh you were 14 that's a
totally different story everyone waits
team seven or eight I don't know I don't
have a good memory great agents all one
big blur and then college my grandpa one
time we spent the night at my grandma
grandpa's house they were both from the
old country my grandpa came to America
when he was 14 by himself it's the old
country always mean Italy it I don't
know where that it means Ireland but it
doesn't oh the old country it depends on
what person you're talking to you sorry
yeah in my family means Ireland every
would have your Sicilian then it was it
a win him in Ireland the boot ah the
boot kicks Sicily the boat so you're the
soccer ball if you're Sicilian and hey
and I called soccer balls don't mess
around and is that racist if I make up
my own thing get all the way your damn
soccer ball what the hell's that mean
well Italy kicks you and you're like a
soccer ball oh oh well too bad I have to
shoot you in the head anyway sorry to to
the dome that's how the mascara wedding
yep it's all Sicilians will shoot you
that's right sorry I'll go out on a limb
they're gonna shoot me anyway I might as
well tell the truth I learned it from
true romance my grandpa one time we
spent the night at my grandma grandpa's
house uh-huh they had a lot of portraits
of Jesus with thorns Oh on his worst
year yes the blue period you might say
and I woke up before my sister and my
cousin Nancy and my grandpa was awake
looking at me and then he waved his hand
and he brought me in and gave me
powdered donut and some tang like I was
the only grandchild he cared about
meanwhile he had 29 grandchildren Wow
but I got some special early morning
grandpa time because he was awake as
early as i was was great kind of not
interesting maybe to everybody but it is
I I think didn't we were gonna say real
specific grandpa stories was our third
podcast idea will these stories have an
ending you then said and I said they
don't have to know good then I said
great that's exactly how mine's going to
go oh I'm sorry well he said he's
getting a coffee okay I guess uh oh no
he's because he's waiting for his back
oh great and we're gonna go up here hell
out of the airport we're just gonna tell
him that we had to go by Delta um going
around we're gonna go around again I'm
sorry I guess we have to okay I was
fighting for his bag he just was saying
getting a coffee because he's waiting
for his bag I didn't realize no that's
right I feel like it the tree is for the
listener hello listeners by the way have
you done any kind of a salutation that
we like to usually do I believe
salutation it said it's the conclusion
Airy doesn't isn't it or is it like a
loja salutation is greeting I thought
its meetings and salutations like hellos
and goodbyes I think it's no I think
it's like hellos and hellos it's too
late so it is so salutations a perfect
example would be Aloha which means hello
and goodbye and it also means serve your
definition yes but if we're in reality
it doesn't so it doesn't look if we
could just look up Charlotte's Web we
would find out exactly what salutation
oh that is some pic I uh I just like to
take things from it might be from babe
no no no some Pig that's Charlotte's Web
all the way someone had a joke recently
and they were quoting what one of the
things the spider weaved in there and it
wasn't that some Pig it was some thought
something was it the big long word yeah
and they do that they just my sister was
here she'd be able to say it oh they
didn't know they didn't know yeah it's
it's been do but yes Lee or ever yeah
yeah it was like some oh well who cares
it's F we hey don't get me started on on
movies with pigs and no maudlin talking
all day
I'll be talking all damn day bit babe
pig in the city was upsetting remember
that I don't I didn't see him go to the
city but I did I remember just him the
original country pig yeah so a great
time he I do oh he was a real pig it's
not like he packed a bag and there no he
didn't wear like a little read faster
okay no how about a bow tie I can deal
with that you could kind of go for that
yeah oh I yes can do um I can go for
that yes can do is that the real words
no it's not it's an i was doing a little
riff of haulin oats I know but are those
the real words I can't go for that uh I
can't go for that no I no can do so I
said I can go for that Oh ah yes just a
little reversal of here and Ted classic
is that were doable i mean i can't i
can't speak for someone like Weird Al
Yankovic but i think his early work it
was just like reversing songs at to
polka right that's right well and also
he did he really sent up some of Michael
Jackson's greatest it's my favorite
being I'm fat I have a banana have a
whole bunch right if you don't like it's
a fad for lunch just eat eat it if it
jam on gem on hwy Owen described Weird
Al and his music I don't think I would
go for that but yes can do honey isn't
it interesting how he kind of stuck
around and everyone it likes him yes for
sure and respect him and people are
coming out of closet or run go oh they
go God Prius you're so indecisive cuz
you have no power in your silent you're
a silent killer those pretty oh why did
you oh I think I know why we let them in
so we could honk at him oh yeah that was
such a weird behavior yeah it was not
smart driving it's very so many bad
girls here great fooling around
great almost there oh man yes can do
yeah i'm texting uh ray text like Howard
Kramer gray like them and sending you
the color of the time and also the make
and mommy it's all a key it's black
don't write gray Honda off black honda
accord what with dog hair and it should
I've written that ok send Sarah he will
know I bet he has dogs himself oh yeah
there's nothing I could do I'm really
ashamed about it and it but now it's
turned over until I have no feeling
about it anymore I hate being at LAX and
you said you liked it gotta get so
uncomfortable here do you really and
it's nice it's not even crowded oh it's
better than we gonna I don't know what
to ask Jake oh let's just um i'm gonna i
want to know there's some general
knowledge things I just want no I don't
know him very well I just know that I
like him and um I think he's a very
receptive person yeah um but you know
who knows he might be uncomfortable the
dog hair might make him sneeze super
bummed out who knows we just have to
play it by ear we have to play it as it
made and that pre has cut us off and
right now it's just forever you see him
in front of you where you want to be and
now I'm reham still mad at that Prius
silent killers you cannot make a car I
don't care of it if it's good for the
invite I do care that it is i take that
nice it's not ever since the advent of
priuses and there's fewer when i moved
here in 2003 to Los Angeles there's so
many Hummers and everything oh my god
those s e-g which are horrible and I
never could see the Hollywood sign now I
can see it all the time and I really
think it is because everyone's buying
smarter cars but absolutely the fact
that it just rolls up and all you can
hear is the tread of the wheat like
there's no motor sounds it's crazy I've
almost been hit by so many pre si yeah
it doesn't make sense like that whoever
thought of that they should have put in
an artificial noise yeah because that's
crazy
yeah like or just baseball card in the
spokes look at they had to wave to their
grandma who's now coming to wearing
black pants and a brown shirt he said
which I oh okay I really like that so
distinctive almost punk rock yeah here
we go um black pants brown shirt Jake
Johansen black bag brown shirt what will
you do oh that's not him don't seem that
guy was coming I honestly thought that
guy was getting into our car I'm gonna
roll down the window at the risk of
making some noise ah the sights and sent
well not the sights but certainly that
sounds boy I do I don't see a my area
there either oh I love his face yeah
he's got a great face yay I'm gonna tell
him you said that oh you just wait you
just wait Leon okay I always wanted it's
open it should be open oh oh open I
always want to help hi hi oh that was
way too high did you hear how high my
voice my there it's okay exclamation of
joy it's okay hi here he comes Jake
Johansen go dancing everybody Johansen
yes well it's covering all the dog hair
how much she has dogs and she's some
move the Sheep but I'm glad I didn't the
sheets clean it would have been funny of
you got under it and it's immediately to
connect the flare just go well it seems
like you're picking up a dog I know I
kind of always am if there's one in the
road and it looks like it doesn't have
an owner I'll grab that back it up okay
let's see if we can get a dog on our way
Jay I'm telling on you Karen Jake as
soon as you came out she's like I look
at his great faith it's through I said
I'm getting telling about my face you
have a great face it's great to see your
face yeah this is just my face I think
it's just it's good I in a roundabout
way me because I'm uncomfortable I we're
saying you're handsome well that's sweet
well you're well that's sweet now he's
on I can't believe I'm in in the back by
myself is it to know is it a little
weird cuz you're talking to the back of
our head
I'm staring at you through the rear of
your mirror it's nice i like your
podcast thank you all right nice to get
a ride from the airport though I was
thinking when I was you know texting you
back and forth it like oh god it's
easier to take a cab than to do this but
but now that I'm in the car I'm really
right are you glad we're not an angry
cab driver I would love it if this
turned into like a meal and then we all
go out tonight get some pizza recording
the whole time a sleepover come on we we
know and especially for the send-off
episodes where we're being bring people
to the airport that's what I really wish
that I you know I mean not to take
anything away from this experience the
way it seems like so far Jake you've
only complained about doesn't like it
seems like you're not enjoying you know
I don't think of myself as a complainer
but maybe it's time to face yeah I that
those early morning ones you know like I
have to go to Columbus on thursday i
think i'm gonna have to leave my house
at five in the morning where will you be
then just out of curiosity will be right
in front your house at for 40 years okay
sequel that's what I smell so let's put
some cliff hangers in this yeah yeah
that's gonna end all today ellipses I
have the worst diarrhea right now and
it's because I ate a bag of diamonds to
be continued to David they become
millionaires or just have a mess on
their head I went into that airplane
bathroom and you never think you're
gonna see a bag of diamonds there but
there was and I thought if I come out
with these they're gonna know that I
have them but if I eat them I can deny
head eat the bag too that's what was the
only reasons people don't eat bags of
diamonds it's a really cut you up on the
way out it's not even the Diamonds it's
that velvety bag thing that's why we
gonna be the problem where the diamonds
in like a purple crown royal they were
sitting on top of the bag and so hey I
didn't I didn't put the diamonds in the
bag cuz I thought looked that's gonna
that's gonna create a real
kind of a bottleneck no pun intended
aight aight the time and separately and
then i also ate the bag I felt like if
you leave the bag in there it's kind of
it oh you want to take a right here oh
yeah let's go right here yeah we're
gonna go to you can go any way you want
did I just make you spill that coffee
just a little bit that's not bad i was
gonna wash these clothes when i get a
hold on i'm coming home that's the
beauty of coming home a man would I be
have been men mad if we were on our way
to the airport now like great now I
gotta be in Ohio all week the cost a
freaking of [ __ ] yeah I just want to add
one thing to the diamond thing I I would
have eaten the bag first just to coat my
stomach oh yeah I've been waiting to say
that well you know we didn't moved on to
a coffee this is the thing everybody's
got an opinion after the fact well I
don't know where you were when I was on
the plane uh I here's the problem with
our early Moines when someone has a 6am
flight and we've gone all the way down
for a four o'clock pickup in Studio City
we're all so tired no one is funny I'm
not funny until I worried about it a lot
yeah I worried about that myself to
write worried that I you know I'm
slightly emotional now oh that must be
part of what happens when you pick
people up at the airport there's a lot
of crying usually on this well it's
chips and you've been traveling you you
would think you would just be used to it
by now but it's it's still not a
pleasant I've only just recently
realized that i've done my career wrong
way well you know a couple weeks ago or
maybe it was a week ago who can even
tell what is a week ago or what's a
couple weeks ago or what happened this
afternoon a norstra damas maybe yeah
everything is so different now that I've
swallowed those diamonds you could do
either one but yeah um I I did a show
down a comedy magic and I thought well
this is gonna be fun i'm headlining down
here and it's low pressure it's tuesday
wednesday night and then it's paul paul
reiser Ray Romano are doing gesetz
so they go on legends of you know TV
comedy people can't believe they're even
in the same room with right right and
then I go on and I realize oh IC mint
the mistake that I've made now it's also
clear I've done my career as if
performing on stage was my job and TV
and movies were this hobby thing that I
did yeah so funny we were talking about
that right before we picked you up and
I've been doing the same thing I just
always wanted to be a comedian for a
living yeah I'm loving it like I was
just in atlanta i worked at the Laughing
Skull it's a great club the chinese club
in the universe it's like an 80 seater
isn't it and i did this low-budget movie
that you're doing what i would say is it
like a favorite thing during the day
sure but that's not the way you're
supposed to be doing movies you're
supposed to be putting your comedy
stand-up career on hold going to do a
big giant movie and you get a sitcom
then you go back to doing stand-up later
on but I've done it the other way around
it's all it's too late to change it now
are you a person that likes acting do
you act and I like the part where you
actually have the job I just want to
point out that things are gonna be
different once I [ __ ] these dives the
whole tone is gonna change yeah my
career is gonna change I mean that like
kind of the that's gonna be an injection
of financial security that I you know
yet to experience in my life now that
things are you know I don't want to kind
of maintain this tone of complaining
because things are fine i'm very happy
well you're probably uncomfortable
though physically just with them in
there you you had there's no way you
weren't feeling that diamonds in there
but it's the hardest substance known to
man right yeah well but I had a big
lunch on the plane too so there yeah
they're kind of mixing around what do
you said it you're probably being out
feeling uncomfortable I thought you were
talking about the back seat of the honda
fit oh I'm gonna [ __ ] again you do I
don't think you're gonna be able to
though look at that right the sheets
there some okay we'll take it easy
there's a kind of Mormon feel to that
set up back there where there's a sheet
for keeping you from doing things oh
yeah I guess I guess it it's bad that
it's not every time there's a sheet back
there the Mormons do with the sheet I
knew that there was a Jewish thing with
a sheet and a board nope oh is it Jewish
like not sure I thought Mormons had a
sheet with a hole were thinking of
special underwear that you can oh that's
right pair of underwear that it's okay
to we should stick to our own religions
and my church you don't have to do any
of that you can do it you know you're
not supposed to have sex until you get
married so I guess I blew it there is
your church Jake well I don't really
have a church I grew up in we were
congregational presbyterian you know
which is kind of the most Protestant
Protestant churches I mean maybe not
Unitarian those guys are pretty fair
lacks that's almost like a you know pot
party I went to I was in a Presbyterian
youth group in high school just for the
pot uh-huh I know I really did and it
was really i even was very open with my
pastor guy that I'd never read the Bible
and kind of saw a lot of holes in it and
maybe was agnostic and he's like that's
okay Wow cuz we have some a bake sale
the run or whatever we just did that's
all business see my family was the
opposite because I was raised Catholic
and we went to summer camp that was
Episcopalian and we came home on a
Sunday and went to like morning Mass
with all the kids we went to camp with
at the Episcopalian Church and then when
we got back to my aunt's house my
grandma was there and she said are they
gonna go to real church now sure she
wanted us to go to Catholic Mass you
know we'd already gone disappear oh and
see from me from my point of view that
Presbyterian Church biskup aliens were
actually very that's the real deal
there's the Henry the Eighth version of
Catholicism right I mean that sort of
the Church of England they kind of he
invented his own church once they
wouldn't let him get divorced and they
and that was what Episcopalians turned
into that's my understanding of it but
again we're little over our heads here
in the hunt right no I are beyond over
my head you're where yeah we're in an
arena I know nothing about I couldn't
finger Henry the eighth in a lineup if I
I mean photo big fat guy he's always
eating a turkey leg you know it's not
that Turkey I've seen him down at the
beach yeah well rennaissance Renaissance
Fair have you ever been to a Renaissance
Faire I've always avoided them should i
have I been wrong this whole time I I
feel like that's a good sequel to this
episode also asked already
they're the only wait I'll go to a
Renaissance Faire if you can promise me
a couple things a person with a snake
and maybe a juggler haha well come on
you I feel like you're setting the bar a
little bit well order it's a tall order
okay we can bring our own snake oh god
they're gonna there's gonna be if
they're there will be a lady with a
snake don't worry good i have a snake
and you know what I forgot to feed it um
Jake yeah how often can see I don't
really want to get serious I want to go
to the renaissance right now I want a
mug of mead from a wench and I've never
really thought of myself as that guy you
know there's the dungeons and dragons
guys like Brian Posehn was telling me he
does a podcast where they just play
Dungeons and Dragons yeah oh that's
great Wainwright yeah I think so but I
mean I can't I don't even know how
Dungeons and Dragons works but either
the Renaissance Fair was pre Dungeons
and Dragons that's all I'm saying yeah
yeah the original cosplay yeah what if
what if instead of coming here and
seeing real people doing these things we
just rolled dice guys and pretend in our
basement that would be yeah we won't
have to do all this hideous interacting
well there's new versions of that what
what is the game there's some not like
risk but a newer version of that about
overtaking the world and people play it
now live it's like rissler game oh oh
yeah a lot of girls play it girls yeah
girls but it's like it's I wish I knew
the name of the game I wish you did too
uh yeah it's almost like I've wasted the
last 20 seconds well we can google this
we'll figure it out later there's table
googling it right now getting mad at us
without knowing what it words what's the
Google girls Renaissance mystery date
boy it's a dating game milton bradley
dating game of thrones twister yeah I
guess it's nothing like Dungeons and
Dragons unless you're into that it's
dating game um yeah I've world of
warcraft I've always wanted to go not no
I'm not around I saw I'd like going to
the Civil War reenactments
Jake how often are you online i'll leave
you ever been to a civil war I'm not I
know we're not playing a game show right
now but i have to say i doubt that i
doubt that you could win the Civil War
when I have been Austin when I first saw
you at the bad dog comedy theater it's
likely they never paid you I did get
paid they're all good kevin meaney
didn't Kevin mean it and he he lived up
to his name he was not happy that was
just a dumb joke but I remember he was
oh wow that's potholes I am my people at
four-wheel-drive trucks in LA and then
and then I go over those potholes and
I'm like okay that made me want to have
no real must really it's just gonna get
worse i don't i don't want to get all
political but I mean I feel like you
were talking about infrastructure right
now and Barack Obama has led us down and
I don't think we're Republicans are
gonna be any help either you know it's
gonna it's all just gonna slowly fall
apart it starts with a hole in the road
and then it ends up with our kids being
homeless hey did you speaking of our
kids did you know there's a measles
epidemic right now yes well I its Connor
one additional land yet started at
Disneyland is what I heard her it but
that's the Epis blows in the center
every once everyone's coming down on
Jenny McCarthy and and she's like become
the poster child for the lunacy of not
inoculating your kids but I the measles
mumps rubella shot when I was a kid gave
me an immediate reaction I had rosacea I
had convulsions I would get very high
fevers and my mom was always like I know
you were fine and healthy until we got
you inoculated than I didn't so I got a
mom that my whole life was kind of
saying that Jenny McCarthy stuff really
except you got the vaccination so you
never came down with the real me
seriously and you've got a great career
we're in a car doing a podcast right now
am I talk yeah you're right i mean so I
almost baked my brain as a baby yeah if
you consider this a high ten here right
all the way around
you've won yeah your mom is wrong but I
agree Jenny McCarthy deserves a break I
mean I don't think enough things have
gone her way what I glean from that is I
have a pretty good life that's what I
keep saying thank you yeah well that's
what I was thinking I was thinking I
wish I was the guy who was picking
people over the airport doing a show
yeah someday I guess so close your
clothes just just stick to it you'll get
there kid that's what I like to say that
too campeon at tehreem to kick now when
I started comedy by the way yeah we both
do yeah we we were talking about that
earlier it's something we should have
mentioned well I really like you guys
too so this is really great what are we
gonna do after this I don't know why
what I looked up to you huh aight i
looked up to you and you said well i
like you guys too oh it's see that's
actually a lot well I didn't think I
couldn't say that I look up to you
because that might weird right i mean
how could we both look up to each other
that's making fun of my height cuz I'm
short it's connection I didn't remember
that about you now that was sorry I'm 59
going on remember i'm actually shrinking
we did a speakeasy together all that
show was so ridiculous was so dark like
the light on stage was not as bright as
your phone the flashlight thing it was
like one wayward christmas a string of
light but it was just one little ball
but now area it was called the
prohibition i think something like i
can't remember it was in culver city oh
yeah and i was booked by our friend LJ
how Jackson hmm and I'd spoke to al
about it he said that the guy the guy
who runs the room got uppity and wanted
to kind of start making all these rules
about the comedians and the blah blah
blah that you know he totally became a
prima donna producer oh no no al had to
yank that show out of that room which is
a real shame the guy took the lights
with him when he left yeah I'm doing a
show tonight under the covers it once my
wife goes to sleep we're gonna do it
under the covers on my side of the bed
but we kind of have to be quiet you need
a tempurpedic bed for that or that we
have that
that cuz a lot of times you know you
know that you'll want to do stand-up and
the wife won't either want to sleep or
drink wine Jake what is your sleep
number yeah what I don't know we have
the tempur-pedic I don't really
understand the sleep number that's a
little after my time but you have to
actually own the bed and read the manual
I don't know anything about it which is
the more firmer is that a higher number
a lower number no idea i've only seen
the commercial a hundred times don't
really know what that i know i have a
sleep number and that's really all
acting yes i'm proud to have one I have
a sealy posturepedic and that's because
you know it makes it easier I can just
electronically elevate my legs for my
gout and then do a craftmatic yeah
craftmatic adjustable I grew up with
water beds and I think that's why I have
scoliosis and number of hip problems I
really did you really have did your
parents have a water bed I had a series
of water beds I have a kid and I child's
water bed well it was warm you know I
grew up in Montana and lived in a
basement my whole life were you ripped I
got out I got out of there yeah the rich
kids in Montana are put in a basement
with the water they get their own
basement water bed oh my god it just
never had enough water in it um so was
like a hammock it was like I was
sleeping in a water hammock right so my
back was always constantly arched hmm
and I think you can all tell with my
very self conscious about my on put yes
oh I love when yes good he works for the
city that's good that he has it he's got
with a reflector vest and a viking
helmet yeah yeah welcome to the
neighborhood yeah some bike ballet he's
just a crossing guard with a lot of
spirit um anyway I'm bad posture are you
at Jake are you a married person to a
family I am I I am I wasn't kidding
about my wife I was kidding about the
podcast in bed with her but I remember
you say mentioning your wife just
moments ago and I obviously i guess i
take my rd of kids that's what I have a
wife and we have a daughter who's 10
that's terrific and that's why I'm not
out that's why we don't get to see each
other more often that's the prot thats
why we have to wait until al Jackson
does this Jonah flashlight show and a
tiny park well I'm gonna see if I can do
something about that I am too i'm trying
to get out more
be amongst more people this is the step
in that direction once this is yeah this
is it well I know many people who would
love to have you on their shows around
town many yeah you could just kind of
take your pick up the ones that are just
fun where you're actually getting work
done cuz I I tend to just do whatever
show someone offers me and I'll dry-eyed
life over here and on the west side like
you and I've all the way to it's a long
way from here to there have you done any
of those shows that are liking so and
like they roll up a garage door and you
do a show in the driveway and sometimes
they're great there there's a there's a
whole spate of living room shows the
space not the right word but there's a
bunch of living or a dearth a bunch of
living room shows where the kids that go
there are so into it there it there like
some of the best shows I've ever done I
totally get why the kids who go there
would be into it but what I don't
understand really is like I feel like we
might have lost track of what we're
trying to do which is you know we're
trying to make a living you know right
now like if you can't ever charge
someone a cover or get paid for doing
stand-up then I mean you're not gonna
get your own sitcom from doing a show in
somebody's living are you though if it's
true I'm ready to do the living room I
don't want to be completely mercenary
about this living room show but I feel
that way when I'm on the road and I go
to some claw the last one that really
made me sleep in the fetal position was
in Houston the joke joint and it was I
never been there it was yeah don't I'm
gonna and they might be listening I'm
sorry your sweet lady Rachel but I uh
well I really hurt my feelings every
night and I'm like I'm certainly not
gonna get a sitcom coming getting 10
yeah I guess you're right yeah it's hard
to know you have to do both though I do
know that it honestly seems like bjs
like in LA if you're in a living room
show the odds that there's some young
assistant to a highly powered person
sitting in that audience in the living
room yeah like that's I swear to god
there's people words just like oh I saw
you at this thing or I'm
why in god's name would you be there
yeah and it's because they as their job
go to just places around town when they
go to like hip things yeah see I don't I
don't need to get paid to do a living
from room show because i have an ass
full of diamonds right now but most
people I feel like you know yeah some of
these young youngsters and they you know
it'd be nice if not only maybe there's
an executive there but they got twenty
dollars I know some shows right it's
funny because people says I would think
it wouldn't happen all the time um oh
we're just three minutes from your house
I know we can go around you can go
around the block if you want to sure we
boy yeah I mean I I want to talk more I
don't mind talking but if we sit get in
the driveway my wife will come out and
make me come in the house I can promise
you that most most most most drop-offs
we've had they make when we come home to
a wife that is angry and coming out with
her hair in curlers oh yeah it's not the
common lot of rolling pins I do wish
wanna get married wife would didn't get
busy with that role it would be so happy
I mean the only thing she uses that
thick boards to chase me around not a
pie in sight though Joe handsome cows
get about it remember when we were in
the Sacramento together um well I wasn't
really on the show I think but it was
Dave Anthony was opening for you and we
get to hang out for a weekend now this
was back in the 90s oh this is a staves
favorite show what's this podcast no I
work with Dave in Sacramento one time
and he's told the show in my podcast a
couple of times and I don't know if he's
if you're thinking about this story
where there's a group of young people in
the audience that are kind of
handicapped and Dave doesn't realize it
oh and they're kind of talking to each
other and doing some making some noises
that are there kind of enthusiastic and
they're supportive and they're really
enjoying the show they've said something
to him once and then they say something
again he goes what are you [ __ ] and
I'm the whole rest of the crowd goes oh
my god of course they didn't care the
kids didn't care they were having a good
time and he meant it as a joke he didn't
hand it as a mean thing but he was so
much more fart I've had these
same thing happened at cap city when i
when i lived in austin there's people in
the back and they were laughing in an
annoyed they were rather than laughing
they're just making an outburst and I I
didn't say I think I said something a
little lighter than [ __ ] but the
entire audience was like whoa whoa
should I go here um we're actually the
other way but yeah yeah yeah but okay
see so take em laughs whenever you well
or you can go up and take a right and
come back to here and then go back i
like i like that i took that like that
better so sorry you called them a name
like return I said I feel like now maybe
I think I may have said the word
[ __ ] I know we're not supposed to
say [ __ ] but I don't think anyone
ever says [ __ ] when they're talking
about a handicapped person i only use
that word when they're talking about one
of their friends is kind of being dopey
yeah or another or that but my bumper
keeps of coming off of Mike Mike are so
[ __ ] yeah well like it would be much
more insulting to say to someone look
are you someone who was a competent
person look what are you learning
disabled that seems more he is insulting
right now you're talking about a real
thing that you would say I don't know me
i said it's more clinical I guess I
think we're not gonna get to the bottom
of you know what it's accurate though
but it's unfortunately accurate because
there are people who identify that it's
not a bad thing that they are [ __ ]
or handicapped mentally handicapped but
Jeff um no I can't remember his
lieutenants a game Sean now start giving
him got him he's the one that son's
career though he's on Curb Your
Enthusiasm okay and he Jeff garlic
garlic yes oh I could it be where's the
crazies on that other show with this
crazy sweaters yes he doesn't yeah he's
on the crazy sweater 85 mmm and he has a
whole bit about how the [ __ ] is the
one word that's like that that we should
be allowed to say because it's so
accurate it is because when you want to
call someone [ __ ] it's cuz they're
being [ __ ] I'm on it just I i only
say when I talking about putting out a
fire
we're slowing down a fire like a fire or
slow or bringing a conversation to a
whole like a nagging conversation
retardant thank you I just wanted
someone else to use it in a sense yeah
but it's okay if you say mentally
returns you take out the word mentally I
don't even think we know this I think
again we're in some deep water here we
don't really know we're talking about
we're in deep water are on tonight's but
either way my dream is for us to start
getting letters do people even write
them anymore yeah they come through the
summer of insane I want to get an angry
letter I've gotten some angry emails you
did I how do they get hold of you but
nothing in your show tonight and you got
angry at the man heckling I don't
believe I found she's very
unprofessional oh yeah like that was the
letter that you got yeah yeah and then I
threw some deduction I I found out it
was the owner's wife a woman who was
pregnant and drinking a beer yes yeah
well this is the other thing that I
think we need to lighten up on I think
it's okay for pregnant ladies have a
glass of wine every once in a while why
these are getting so a beer nowadays
people having nine ten pound infants I
just got off a plane so tell me about it
you know there are some big human beings
and maybe a couple drinks during
pregnancy could solve this problem i'm
not i'm back in the TV they don't give a
[ __ ] well sing that song sing the danger
zone okay so what you wanted to do was
go up and get ramped up here okay i can
take a right turn down the corner we are
just making sure we have exactly an hour
in 10 minutes yeah the greatest this is
a great bow you can't even turn there
yes or take well you can't I this is one
way the wrong way so yeah you're gonna
have to take a right here and then go
back you just take a right on Main
Street well that's a one way we did
where he's don't matter no matter what
we say do not go the wrong way
one way it's just a good idea yeah
although it in kind of convenient if you
I don't matter what I say not untie me
oh it's nice to live out here isn't it
the best is I moved out here a long time
ago after yeah that's right is it pilot
that didn't go I thought well I'm gonna
move by the beach so I have sanity yeah
and it's really worked but it sort of
put a real kind of damper on drive one I
can drive over to Silver Lake and do a
shot yeah I'm constantly going back and
forth i love waking up over here I feel
like I when I the brief period i was in
West Hollywood I was overwhelmed with
everything and then get over here do you
just go the beach for no reason we go
surfing down there my wife and I have to
come with us why are we hanging out more
Chris this is what I want to know I said
I have I got a I got a surfboard from
from costco and then I have a little one
that I'm horrible hon but I'd like
surfing okay well we can go to the beach
we can go have coffee I am I absolutely
want to do that there's not a lot of
westside friends I mean I am still in
the car afternoon will your Karen come
on you're invited if you would just
ditch that ridiculous day job you've
guts held us back we could have done
this podcast two months ago it wasn't
for you you stupid paper your home
owning in the valley you know what else
in the valley Valley for I don't know I
don't know it's not any furniture i'll
tell you that if that was your next
question i live in an empty house an
empty house it's an art project only
furnitures for the dogs do you have a
are you uh you know relationship is that
going I'm out of a release you can turn
right if you want oh please don't hit
that incredibly attractive young lady
there's a lot of well there's a lot of
attractive people here by the beach okay
you'll find that yes yes and you move
out here Karen when when we all get
aloft out here I feel like I'm ready for
a clubhouse in my life we could start
our own comedy show at the clubhouse
yeah so I'm down it's club you want to
go up right up to the next block and
then you can turn right or you can pull
over if you want to just chat for a
little while first what
pilot that you were talking about that
that was it that one yeah I've had 70
listen that's great I have not i've been
to the plate a number of times i had
pilot that was in nineteen right after i
got to town 80 oh this 78 and why
visitors and fish and it didn't go it
was this is the story of that
disappointment brandon tartikoff was the
one he was the president of the network
at the time and his daughter was in a I
can't remember if this was this one or
the next one but I think it was this one
he was in a car accident with his
daughter was in a car accident so he was
kind of off the scene the show got
developed then when the show was done he
was kind of back and he goes no no this
isn't what I said I wanted to make no
we're not doing this and then there was
the writer strike and then the show they
called up and said look they don't have
anything to put on television so they're
going to air the pilot they're not
picking up but it's gonna be on TV and
then the writers strike ended oh that's
just all that was like a triple jerk
around it was it well I don't I wasn't
counting but yeah you're right sounds
like a triple sounds like a triple I
feel like it was a triple I did another
one for Fox where the it was a it was
this presentation it was during when
they were like we're not doing pilots
anymore because pilots you got to pay
people like double what they would get
to if you was an episode of the show so
instead we're gonna do presentations
which is we'll put it up like a theatre
play yeah and then we'll just decide if
we want it based on that and then they
and I said okay well it seems kind of
crappy because now they're gonna pay you
a tenth of what you would get for a
pilot did you do it on stage like some
way they rehearse it for a week as if it
was an actual they were going to shoot
it but then then and then they said well
you know what we are going to shoot it
just because maybe everybody can't be
there to watch it so we're gonna shoot
it but it's not a pilot it'll just send
it around and though my manager said
well you can't shoot it if you're gonna
do that and they said okay well we don't
what about VHS and it goes know about a
courtroom artist yeah a stenographer so
the so the schedule that one I did with
Tom Thomas at Thomas F Wilson my friend
Tom Wilson oh yes a lot of people know
back to the future yeah which yes I
don't even like to say that cuz he's not
he's done so many other great things and
it's not his favorite thing but that's
maybe he would bring it out port it's a
great role wouldn't he everyone can't
help it cuz everybody yeah he has to
like say they want to put that saddle on
him and ride him around like their
birthday so but he and I are doing this
thing and it was so much fun and then
and Peter Bonners you know the guy the
guy from the pop new heart shadow that
was a guy who directed it it was a
really fun week and then the we were
they were gonna do the presentation on
friday they're not gonna videotape cuz
all the executives are going to show up
and it was raining like it was a brutal
raining night and so some of the
executives showed up but not all of them
Barry Diller was the head of Fox he did
not show up on that Friday Monday he
announced he was leaving fox to go to
QVC Oh God yeah so that is this second
in my series of Hollywood nut punch um
no that that was definitely three
multi-directional yeah it's a deal that
didn't super good but it was that was
back in flat I was definitely counting
those punches just one to each night I
think traditionally is how that goes in
Hollywood okay a dual simultaneous well
like I would yeah maybe I'll write a
pilot you want to be in my we're
teachers uh to solve that on our chart
here's my pilot it's all child my child
murders are very hot right now ma I'd
watch it fellas brick British drama
shows are all about there's a dead child
yeah let's get to the bottom of it and
then did you watch broadchurch yes
spoiler alert everyone in that town is a
pedophile [ __ ] it's this little tiny
town and everybody's [ __ ] kids are in
love with them yeah holy cow is that
English yeah yeah when I I did stand-up
I haven't gone to the UK a bunch but i
did a a club in manchester in every
comic there had no files dido beautiful
yeah yeah they it's like oh that's how
they say it over there and they all
laughed they're like oh that's my
favorite thing to make fun of whereas
here people are kind of like hey that's
serious i had a nephew yeah that what
God shown something in a pool house
so that's it's off-limits but in the UK
they it's pedophile this pedophile that
well right cuz they're all pedophiles
can't I guess I want to hear my pitch
for my Oh eyelet yeah we are we in it
yeah it's called pool house okay and you
guys both the work there and there's
okay here's a towel boys in the pool
house okay and it's mostly kids it's
just every week at different kid wanders
in their name you take them away and
then a curtain will blow I think I black
i'd be willing to see a presentation of
that okay but I'm not right I like a
entation this you've just described just
the first you know what do they call
that first two minutes before the show
starts kind of a very cool dope this is
just a cold open yes yes right but then
what happens afterwards will murder that
kid okay and then whatever else you want
I mean what I feel like Moses those are
popular when they it's the people who
are the main characters of people catch
the murderer not the yeah actually wanna
be on their side I mean you're the one
with a TV writing job here's the thing I
think you both need to be willing and
brave just to be an unlikable character
every once in a while but as the stars
yeah we're talking about a second I've
been listening to this episode I feel
like we've all been taking turns being
unlike we're about as unlikable as you
can get idea for the recharge terrific
hmm well weird let's face it we're at
your place we're sitting in a turned-off
car we can start up I'm we're actually a
few blocks away so we drive yeah are we
really yeah we're not here no we're not
here I told you I said to pull over so
we could talk a little bit more we go
into my driveway my wife is gonna come
out no I her she's a character mrs.
Johansen will be on oh she could jump in
I said she was gonna take my name and
then she didn't she didn't do it yeah
mess it's not like a bone of contention
it's just a factual thing that I was
that we've been married for gonna it'll
be 12 years oh that's rocktober that's
did you hear my phone notes that's her
texting me where are you
love can't that's what she says wait for
it and come out just don't stroller a
blazing yeah if you print up the
paperwork and just put it on her desk
make it easy for her what's the
paperwork for her name change oh maybe
it's the clerical stuff and going that
city all this overwhelmed she was like
paper she might have done that you know
her well it sounds like a parent I know
I know her type that's what's stopping
me from a lot of things too is the paper
yes yeah yeah the living room comedy
show paperwork that you don't want to
get certainly the reason I even paid my
taxes and find yours are we gonna be
coming closer yeah it's just will you go
over this next thing and then it's on
the right oh I remember now yes what do
you remember from well the firm tripod
ride his bike past your house oh I don't
know yeah I got a brand-new pain my
friend is now managing her her name is
Melanie yeah my friend is managing her
yeah did she have another hit she's
still rockin out yay um I can't remember
her other hits but yeah she has a good
she's had a couple of hits I didn't know
that she's still doing it take a right
take a take well no there's someone in
the driveway right there right there oh
yeah no next to that one with a silver
car that went back with that house is it
droopy it's almost like it's melting I
love it we're going in here do you live
in that okay no I'm did you see what
that blue car yes over there I'm in the
one next to though I like that too
behind the other kind of sage green e1
do you want me to back up and go back
over there well you can okay oh she's
not gonna she's fine hi how are you she
was she really has a curious look on her
face yeah well she is a curious person
probably coming out because that might
be someone oh one of her friends car or
maybe she's mad at the person who left
the car she lives in this building where
that driveway goes to or that building
this not in this this building that
we're parked in I don't know the people
who live here that much could be
blocking somebody well what they'll but
they'll either be in the road or they'll
come up this driveway and they'll have
an angry look on there for the calories
guy in the neighborhood though lives
behind that building very real he's
famous his default mode is to just start
every time something's a problem he just
starts yelling at you his life you know
how they say you make your own world
you know he's the star of that Wow well
certainly the look on her face could be
confused for anger I don't it might be
just her resting thing to do with us but
yeah it's probably just a lifetime of
being mistreated I bet it's that jean
jacket it's a tiny bit might be the
fringe on that skirt that's making very
angry it's just the denim on denim that
she has come and you don't even know
what kind of undergarments she's done
yeah yeah sometimes you want that I'm
just big floppy granny bloomers just
like I was in shock i was thinking more
of kind of a religious kind of like
there's a tight thing or some magic
under what she's worth way more better
she just drapes a sheet with a hole in
it around her waist or its chain mail oh
she could choose from the ren faire good
I don't need her permission she has a
channel v belt okay Jake what any plugs
and yeah yeah yeah I don't rate when is
this gonna be coming out you know Larry
here's what the next Monday here's what
I can say to you people listening to
this um I've got a comedy special that
you can download it's five dollars and
you can download it from my website Jake
this calm and that's my website so you
can find out where on place com what's
the comedy special what's the title yeah
called pictures of my dinner I love that
name I'm going to watch that you also
have other one you have a have I love
you on net you can watch out on that no
you can't anymore they really a Yank I
watched it on there I know they put this
is do you want to hear about another
kind of way that show biz disappoint you
yes they can stop having you on that we
didn't know that they could do but I was
like what happened and not only do they
take the special off but they remove all
the reviews and the record of it being
on there so so for a while it was like
you could go on and you could say well
if this ever comes back I want to watch
it or you could read reviews that people
have written though about it but it was
on for three years and then and now it's
not I'm gonna put that up for digital
don't take that personally it hurts
instead of charge five bucks for that
one since it's the old one get for free
on your web I thought we I thought you
were gonna suggest ten dollars i mean
all money what money is really kind of
classic okay seven that's all the
technicality now that I'm I've got these
diamonds
so everything is now yeah whole world is
shifted dramatically I know it's all for
fun now yeah everything is for fun it's
great I can't wait to see you guys at
the living room I show that we're gonna
do why don't we buy a house that we just
do living room shows I nobody even lives
in I mean if you make the down payment
you're the one that [ __ ] and money will
the paceman up with dead children a
dream house you're saying yeah 3 mouth a
little place that's just for us and our
predilection I don't think this was
gonna be that much fun no you got you
had low expectations kind of dreading it
a little bit no I was excited about it
but i but I really didn't this was more
fun than I thought good I'm glad that
you're saying that and I'm glad I hope
that it was better than the cab ride it
certainly I'm yeah just go ahead all
this beats the crap out of a cab what do
i owe you know Cologne starting with no
Cologne and then we actually knew how to
get to your house the pain sort of we
spiraled in but we did it you know
roundabout way the payment is in having
made you've paid us in laughs if you
want to go right if you want to park at
my driveway you can come in and meet my
wife if you want to no thank you no I
didn't like so okay I'm a little nervous
just anyone in curlers wheel it's not
really where you made that up that's not
who she really is I bet retracing my
said if that was my whole time Kitchener
is pet from Andy Capp and I don't want
any part of it I'd [ __ ] that mean that
pet from a kneecap makes me want to take
a facebook nap nap on the couch memory
bug nap on his face yep Oh junk he was
abusive he was a terrible drunk han
hecho en they were so yeah I don't
remember Andy Capp as well as you guys
and you're younger than me too thats
it's weird it's very turnabout thing the
temp it's a turnaround oh it's well Jake
I minute I'm going to make you do um
Loki shows in Hollywood okay I want to
okay is it is we're done now right I
keep thinking like I should put this
down but then it's not really over
talking this is over right isn't it okay
we're gonna get out fizzle out oh here's
okay go ahead you the sign off we will
Oh
first um yeah you're trying to say
something yeah Jake thank you for being
on the show we very much enjoyed you
this is my conclusion Airy voice oh I
think you've been listening to do you
need a ride dyn AR AR AR AR AR AR AR AR